Welcome back.
In the last lesson you deployed
a small Hadoop cluster.
I'm sure you can imagine that setting up
a larger cluster the same way would be
too tedious.
Just ten more, just ten more,
just ten more.
Luckily for all of us, there is
software that automates deployment.
Apache Ambari makes it much
easier to provision, monitor, and
maintain Hadoop clusters.
They'll also install common applications
built on HDFS, such as Hive and Spark.
We'll use it to create a larger cluster,
like the one you'd
have at a real company.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Again, the cluster will be deployed on
Amazon EC2 instances since you don't
have server racks.
However, Ambari can also be
used with common hardware.
The process is pretty straightforward,
I'll lead you through it.